Ferguson is in there for the rebound
Westbrook courts people selfies
let's go by the glaciers come on we'll
face George
[Applause]
and then that words on that drive
officials are going to take a look at
[Applause]
watch this up on Westbrook on
[Applause]
good acting on your case or that's
exactly what he's supposed to do
[Applause]
now I would like to see what happened
after the drive by Westbrook because it
looked like Newark achieve had words or
a little bit of a shove to Westbrook
initially here's the drive by Westbrook
now watch after the play here after he
saves the basketball
here's the save by Newark itch let's see
if there's contact before this
[Applause]
[Music]
well spurt loss is cool
left foot
harkishen
well I got to see the game you are you
saying this part it was a thought that
left foot kind of kicked out a little
bit okay
but I'd like to see it one more time
[Applause]
this isn't this is again
[Applause]
then the play Center in Secaucus is came
Fitz Joan so you're wondering if that is
intentional